est-ce qu'il faut acheter un nouveau mac
m est ce que ces nouveaux mac moins
chères peuvent remplacer vos anciens mac
intel qui vous en coûter un rare mais
surtout qu'est ce que ça donne au niveau
performance ça tombe bien parce que j'en
ai un sous la main et que je les tester
en long en large et en travers
et je vais vous dire le fond de ma fin
mai juste après l'intro
[Musique]
et salue les jaunards à l'écran c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique moi
encore je suis ravi comme toujours de
vous retrouver pour une nouvelle vidéo
où on va parler de montage de vidéos de
performance de ma clé d'ordinateurs de
mac m1 parce que oui tout le monde en
parle de ces nouveaux mac ya eu plein de
tests plein de rêves ue et moi j'avais
envie de vous donner un petit peu mon
avis puisque j'ai testé en long en large
et en travers pour faire de la vidéo du
montage pour faire de la photo de la
retouche de l'export et même un petit
peu plus et je pense que ça vaut le coup
d'en discuter parce que vous avez été
très très très très très nombreux sur un
stade à me poser plein de questions
dessus parce que les benchs c'est bien
ça donne une idée des performances et
tout mais dans la vraie vie
qu'est ce qu'ils valent ces maquettes en
est ce que on peut faire du montage avec
est-ce que ils vont encaisser est-ce
qu'ils ont les performances suffisantes
pour le faire ça on en parle tout de
suite alors très rapidement pour ceux
qui savent pas ces nouveaux mac et main
ce sont la nouvelle génération de mac
que apple a présenté il ya quelques
temps ils ont la particularité d'avoir
une nouvelle architecture il se passe
des processeurs intel qu'ils avaient
habituellement pour des processeurs
maison fabriqués par apple et ça donne
en fait une puce qui s'appelle apple
silicone la première qui est la m1 et
dans cette puce en fait il ya tout il ya
le processeur et la carte graphique et
al ahram
il ya le disque dur bref c'est un tout
en un et s'est annoncée par apple comme
ayant des performances totalement folle
pour une consommation totalement
ridicule alors je n'avais pas
spécialement envie de changer puisque
comme vous savez j'ai déjà un macbook
pro 16 pouces qui marche très bien mais
j'étais super dubitatif au niveau des
performances de ces matchs musique ce
n'était pas possible en fait qu'apple
ait pu réussir à faire des choses aussi
puissante qu'il l'annoncé surtout à un
prix aussi bas
ce qu'elle est ça aussi mon macbook pro
m'a coûté très cher et là j'ai pris le
mac mini entrée de gamme c'est à dire
qu'il a 8 gigas de ram qui que dalila
256 go de disque dur de ssd et le fameux
processeur m
sachant que mon usage la plupart du
temps en dehors de la bureautique et du
surf c'est de la vidéo du montage vidéo
avec final cut quasiment tout le temps
en 4k et de la retouche photo et
l'export de photos et parfois beaucoup
de fichiers photos alors je vais pas
vous faire attendre plus longtemps qu
est ce que ça donne niveau performances
eh ben j'ai été mais totalement bluffé
parce que la machine en caisse
tout ce que je lui ai demandé le montage
quatre cassettes vidéo elle est montée
sur le mac mini avec 8 gigas de ram
ces deux-là quatre cas avec des effets
avec de la colle aux jets monter
d'autres projets plus de dix minutes je
les ai exporter ça va vite ça va
quasiment aussi vite que mon macbook pro
c'est hallucinant à quel point c'est
rapide idem pour la retouche sous
lightroom
c'est fluide ya pas de latence ya pas de
lag tout va extrêmement vite même si
lightroom n'est pas encore optimisé pour
apple silicone parce qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'il ya des applications qui sont
optimisés pour un peu le silicone et
d'autres qu'ils ne le sont pas encore
fine pointe par exemple il est
complètement optimisé il a été réécrit
totalement pour fonctionner sur cette
architecture arm donc les performances
sont bien meilleurs mais pour toutes les
autres applications apple a mis en place
un virtualiseur qui s'appelle rose est à
2 qui va se charger en fait de traduire
le langage des processeurs intel vers le
langage des processeurs arm donc toutes
les applications qui fonctionne sur mac
os d'habitude sont censés fonctionner
aussi sur ses mac
m en terme de vidéo que ce soit les
fichiers internes du set 6-2 en cas de
cas ça passe crème
j'ai testé également et je vous montre
des fichiers en s l'octroi un cadre de 2
10 bits du sony à 7 est roi ça passe
nickel et j'ai même poussé le vice à
mettre des fichiers raid
huit cas que j'ai récupéré sur le site
de raids en attendant d'avoir la mienne
et là encore la machine ne bronche pas
et l avis giga de ram c'est ça qui est
juste fou et même un ensemble plein
d'appuis simultanément un export
lightroom un export final cut
elle a à peine s'est dit d'ailleurs
j'étais très déçu parce que - l'hiver
j'ai la petite habitude pour me
réchauffer les doigts de poser mes mains
de temps en temps sur ma machine qui
fait office de radiateur est mal ah non
le machin ne chauffe pas maintenant si
on devait comparer un petit peu par
rapport au mcs actuelle à la gamme intel
alors j'ai pas fait les benchs mais
didier de la chaîne mc forever on a fait
plein il les a envoyés pour je puisse
vous les montrer et si ça vous intéresse
d'aller voir du côté des benchs pure et
bien je vous encourage à aller voir ses
vidéos que je vous mets en description
mais grosso modo ce qui apparaît c'est
que par rapport à leurs homologues
intel 1 qui était de l'entrée de gamme
les nouveaux mac henin explose toutes
les performances que ces matelas pouvait
avoir maintenant s'ils concernent des
plus grosses machines c'est un peu plus
serré mais là où on peut se dire qu'on a
les boules c'est que ce match là en
question le mac mini que j'ai coûte 800
hop à 799 mon macbook pro 13 pouces je
les payais pratiquement
4000 euros et grosso modo sur ses
performances on n'est vraiment pas très
loin avec ses mac mini et ses macbook
pro des performances de mon macbookpro
16 pouces alors est ce qu'il est bon à
jeter à la poubelle mon macbook pro eh
ben c'est pas si évident que ça ya des
points négatifs sur ces nouveaux mac m1
le premier gros point négatif que je
vois c'est la compatibilité des plugins
alors pour ce qui est de final cut
récemment les seuls plugin compatible
que j'ai pu voir c'est ce de motion vfx
qui est d'ailleurs un site qui propose
de très très bons de plugins je vous
mets un liant description c'est pas
affiliés ces cadeaux ça fait plaisir
ils ont mis à jour pas mal de plugins
pas tous encore les principaux que
j'utilise mais pour des suites de
plugins comme red giant par exemple que
j'utilise j'utilise la suite univers
c'est magic bullet bâle a par exemple
c'est inutilisable
alors j'ai pas testé tous les éditeurs
bien sûr mais il ya quand même des
chances pour que les plugins que vous
utilisez ne soit pas compatible
actuellement avec les mac m et ça pour
un pro c'est juste pas possible
et de la même manière on n'a pas
forcément tous pensé aux petits
programmes qu'on utilise une fois de
temps en temps mais dont on a besoin
pour un pro pour un projet bien
spécifique on sait pas encore exactement
ce qui est compatible et ce qui ne l'est
pas et ça encore une fois ça altère un
petit peu ma confiance dans la machine
star je ne sais pas peut-être que je
peux me retrouver face à un problème et
me dire badens
il me faudrait un mac intel avec un
hacker n'a pour l'instant je ne peux pas
sauf que j'ai un client qui me demande
un truc et je peux pas lui faire donc ça
c'est le plus gros point noir que je
vois l'autre point noir c'est la
limitation à 16 giga de ram
alors c'est un point noir sans en être
vraiment hein parce que déjà avec 8
gigas de ram
le truc est fou mais apparemment selon
les différentes belges qui ont été faits
pour des tâches comme les exports de
fichiers type 8k raid les mac avec 16
giga de ram fonctionne beaucoup mieux
ils sont beaucoup plus performants
alors tout le monde n'était pas de la
vie car elles ont pour la plupart des
fichiers que j'ai pu tester sa passe et
crème mais faut le savoir quand même
faut dire que peut-être ça va pas être
une bécane qui va hyper bien vieillir
dans le temps pour un pro enfin j'ai
parlé de final cut mais en ce qui
concerne première pour les utilisateurs
de première pour le moment le logiciel
n'est pas optimisé pour les puces à main
il fonctionne il fonctionne même plutôt
bien mais il n'est pas encore optimisé
tout comme
lightroom tout comme photoshop qui ont
été annoncées pour être compatible cours
en 2021
mais on sait pas trop quand encore une
fois donc ça fonctionne mais ça
fonctionne pas encore au meilleur de ses
performances
et c'est un peu un pari que de se dire
ouais bon bah j'achète un mac m1 et je
suis sûr que ma suite adobe va
fonctionner hyper bien d'ici six mois
là encore elle peut-être mieux attendre
un petit peu pour voir il ya aussi le
fait que les cartes graphiques externes
ni gpu ne sont pas compatible avec les
mac
m les mac les reconnaissent ils les
voient ils se disent tiens il ya un gpu
salut il a pu
et ils font rien avec en fait ils font
juste lui faire coucou c'est c'est un
peu dommage quand même malgré le fait
que le processeur graphique soit ouf sur
les jeux on a vu que les jeux optimisés
comme fortnight ou comme world of
warcraft tourner avec des performances
sur le des machines comme le macbook air
une pure tuerie en termes de connectique
a dû plus il ya du moins c'est à dire
que sur le mac mini c'est pas trop mal
on a un hdmi que j'utilise moi pour mon
moniteur ensuite on a deux thunderbolt 3
et 2 usb classique ce qui me fait quatre
ports pour brancher des périphériques
ce qui est plutôt pas mal en revanche
sur les macbook air et sur les macbook
pro il ya seulement deux ports
thunderbolt roi et là c'est vraiment
très très très très très limite il
faudra acheter un homme en plus pour
pouvoir avoir plus de porc ça va être
galère des trucs d'un travail de chien
autant atteindre une version 16 pouces
qui proposera quatre ports et là on sera
déjà beaucoup beaucoup
alors on va répondre à la question de
départ est ce que c'est une bonne
opération aujourd'hui que d'acheter un
mac
m ah bah ça dépend de qui vous êtes si
vous êtes un pro je le déconseille
complètement c'est difficile aujourd'hui
de vous dire vous pouvez aller acheter
un hacker main les yeux fermés ça me
paraît un petit peu dangereux ou alors
conservé une machine intel au cas où
mais se dire qu'on va utiliser seulement
ça moi aujourd'hui j'aurais tendance à
vous conseiller d'attendre un type ne
serait-ce que ce soit pour voir comment
évoluent les différents logiciels dessus
ou alors encore mieux attendre une
prochaine génération qui sera
probablement encore plus puissante par
contre si vous faites de la vidéo en
amateur que vous avez pas forcément deux
clients de choses comme ça que vous le
faites pour le plaisir
écoute machine n'est pas tout jeune si
vous avez un match c'est pas moins de
2014 2013
là clairement ça vaut complètement le
coup
mais vraiment parce que c'est des super
machine je n'en reviens toujours pas que
des machines aussi peu cher qui
consomment aussi peu d'énergie arrive à
des perfs aussi énorme
c'est juste incroyable et ça me fait me
dire une chose qui va être un petit peu
la conclusion de ça j'ai de nouveau x en
apple parce que j'avais un petit peu car
du la fois il faisait plus rêver en fait
apple c'était vraiment des petits trucs
en plus mais y avait rien de fantastique
là avec ces nouvelles générations cette
nouvelle architecture
ça promet des trucs de fou j'imagine
très bien
un nouveau macbook pro 13 pouces un
nouveau mac pro les imac
s'ils continuent comme ça ça va être
extraordinaire et on va avoir des
machines accessible parce que là on
parle d'une machine à 800 euros hyper
performantes
jusqu'à présent on pouvait se dire apple
c'est cher pour ce que c'est aujourd'hui
avec la puissance qui a derrière
franchement je pense que c'est une
époque qui est révolu apple revient dans
la course est vraiment très très très
très fort en tout cas moi j'ai adoré
bosser sur ce mac et vous faire cette
vidéo et si vous aussi ça vous a plu
vous pouvez mettre le traditionnel coup
deux blaster sur le pouce en l'air qui
situe juste en dessous de cette vidéo
pouvait me donner votre avis dans les
commentaires ce que vous pensez de ces
nouveaux mac est ce que vous pensez en
acheter un ou est ce que vous pensez
rester sur un mac intel
et puis moi les amis je vous dis rester
curieux et à très bientôt pour une
prochaine vidéo coucher ouais j'avais
envie d'un retour aux sources
en fait ça faisait tellement longtemps
que j'avais pas tourné ici et je me suis
posé la question est ce qu'avec le matos
que j'ai maintenant est-ce que ça va
rendre bien est-ce que ça va être sympa
et je suis assez contente du résultat
d'ailleurs dites moi ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires